[Music]
this australian guy goes for a jog after
heavy rain
and on the ground discovers what looks
like an alien embryo whoa
is the blue thing there are mangas it's
just a squid whoa that's a oyster it's
just a squid so uh he sent he took a
video of it pictures and then they sent
it to like some experts and so far they
can't tell what the [ __ ] it is is it a
live she didn't save it here you go wow
that would have saved it well he poked
it with a stick so that's close is it
ocean inside wow there is some wild some
crazy wildlife in australia why does
that look like a [ __ ]
wait is it dead salamander whoa that's
like a [ __ ] some people think it's
like a deformed frog or it's like a you
can't move it oh like it's stuck onto
the concrete
it kind of looks like it is right why is
it so hard and that's squishy
we need to get a whoa what though that's
kind of nuts you guys think aliens are
among us right now yeah okay really why
do you think so why do i think that
um
i mean it depends right because
i think that the ufo [ __ ] now that
they're talking about it more right and
it's like open and you you can even be
in the military and talk about how you
saw some [ __ ] yeah so you know who's
driving that [ __ ] that's all
is it aliens is it
is it russians i mean if it's russians
why wouldn't they just go [ __ ] you cramp
immediately like with the ufo
you dig yeah ufos can [ __ ] up whole
countries immediately well if you could
pull those kinds of news off my friend i
think it's pretty uh pretty much
straightforward yeah they could they
could pretty much wreck a whole country
haven't they found like
what they've uh thought were embryos or
like dead bodies of aliens quote-unquote
and they're at roswell i don't know but
like i remember there was a i don't know
if there was a story or was it recent or
not but there was like a picture like a
blue
embryo or like a alien are you familiar
with this at all so it's probably
[ __ ] then because aren't you really
into aliens i'm also into [ __ ] too
though so i've got you there yeah never
mind then all right
what i brought to the table doesn't help
at all no
so uh here's some other uh suspicions of
what it could be some people think it's
a clam or a snail without a shell but
has an eye doesn't it a snail without a
shell isn't that a slug they also yeah i
guess it could be they also think it
could be a
possum
embryo gabriel
maybe yeah it could be because they like
in a pocket and then they fall out yeah
oh possums are marsupials yeah it's the
only marsupial that we have here
actually on this car yeah but that's
australia yeah so that's do they have
pasta yeah they got everything it just
looks like it squid to me am i nuts but
the way the dew is poking it it looked
hard huh consistency yeah it didn't seem
like it was anything that was of like
actual not even just like uh jellyfish
nature but like even if it was like an
embryo or whatever i guess
maybe it's like rigor mortis type stuff
yeah maybe yeah it looks all hard maybe
it did it was like a hard piece of
bubble gum stuck on the concrete after
it dried up on a sunny day that's
actually one of the uh suggestions too
they thought it was like bubblegum and
it has an eye doesn't it it has what it
looks like could be a knife can you turn
around it looks like um
it looks like a newt baby before it went
full newt oh see
yeah it looks like a tadpole that went
full tadpole or maybe it's a fishing
bait and they also said it could be a
the embryo of like a glider you know
like those like blue
oh sure what i don't know enough uh
australian animals in the local terrains
in what way would an embryo
find itself outside like that a human
one maybe a weird demented kid like joe
got a hold of the mother and just
started [ __ ] with it
come on man i don't do that anymore
don't judge me like
come on nipping eyes off a slug the frog
barrier it was a rainy day
it was a rainy rain it's raining right
there they say where this was by like a
pond sydney oh no no but like is this by
like a pond like a lake or like um an
ocean i don't know i don't think so it's
like literally on the street it's just
on the sidewalk with no so there's no
like australian wildlife expert that's
like oh that's this embryo there's i
think if you're gonna ask an expert i
think you're gonna get even more of an
inconclusive result because they want to
be sure they're right so if you're just
showing people so you got to ask like an
amateur they're probably going to go i
don't know what it is you know like but
if you ask like a [ __ ] amateur it'll
be like [ __ ] squirrel nut
it's a testies of a squirrel they like
they're just fell out some so definitive
but yeah they did try to ask a bunch of
experts and they all were like oh we'd
have to do tests we're not touching this
i have to [ __ ] put it in my mouth i
don't know how the [ __ ] they do that's
why no one listens to experts man they
never have any good opinions because
they're so afraid to lose their jobs
that's kind of true though yeah so
[ __ ] wacky that's kind of true yeah
they're not willing to put it all on the
line for a [ __ ] street squad yeah
they're like why don't you guys have
more experts on jk news and i'm like
cause they're [ __ ] boring yeah they
always go i don't know i don't know
because they're scared of getting fired
and [ __ ] we need brave people who don't
know anything about the topic and they
would [ __ ] go off on it
let's roll
makeup statistics makeup stats yeah
asked me about [ __ ] makeup dude nick
what do you actually think it is
i think it's like a squid that's what i
think just some chinese guy dropped his
[ __ ] honestly think it's like a
coincidence like that and then we're all
just like oh [ __ ] i don't know what hey
remember when the in-n-out burger was in
like new york and everyone's like why is
this in-n-out burger on the ground and
some guy's like yeah i flew here and it
fell out of my bag
no [ __ ] it's the most like common most
boring thing probably
everybody's poking at the in and out
burger with this thing
what is that is that an embryo
everyone's explain this how can you
explain this all the experts are like
i'd have to taste it i don't know man
no experts like i don't want to comment
on it because i can't taste it i'm gonna
lose my job
it's performance art that also happened
with in norway they found a hard hat
from like the like the main department
of power you know like the italy in
norway or norway the main department of
power like from straight from maine
like that you're talking about like
state of maine oh yeah
that's what i'm saying they found a hard
hat like that washed up in norway norway
all the way from maine and all it did
was it just fell in the water and
traveled 3 300 miles it just washed up
great
crazy that the back of it never filled
up with water enough to sink
crazy
google the uh blue alien embryos yeah no
there is something like that bro you
know about it no no he's just talking
about it honestly i'm just a little bit
more interested in that than [ __ ]
squid on the floor well i thought
somebody would have saw that honestly
all of it looks weird one's the one that
he's probably yeah let me see this one
looks legit though i don't have a penis
or anything dude i think this is the one
i think this this is pretty legit really
it's not a smurf
that one a real smurf would also be like
whoa oh my god make it big make it big
what if they got it wrapped up like a
[ __ ] baby yeah guys looks like a bag
of flour why's he got human clothes it
got smaller
why's it got human clothes on that's
pretty crazy i'm asked the expert so is
that the one you're thinking about no
that's not the one i saw no that's not
it you're sure he's like yeah
show me another one i'm not impressed
you think aliens would look like us
like bipedal [ __ ]
like
you know kind of like humanoids yeah
have you ever seen k-pack yeah i like
k-pop that's what kevin spacey says he's
like how do you how does the bubble form
he's like every time that you ever make
a bubble no matter where you are it
forms the same way doesn't it so then
that's the idea that everything would be
bipedal like uh oh because it's the most
like most like it makes sense the most
yeah but when i watched that movie i
didn't know he was a sexual harasser so
it was easier to understand yeah now i
don't like the movie anymore yeah you
can't see past that i love capex though
that was a dope movie but that's
probably true though they probably are
like bipedal or something like that
probably bipedal probably bisexual for
sure
that's the most believable alien i think
so yeah
tall tall long guy with long fingers i
want my aliens have long fingers like
like like a like a like like salad
fingers yeah yeah i think men and black
did it right because i think they're
insects dude i think they think they
look hella insecty
how about the reptilian theory
have you what's the reptilian theory oh
like q anon type [ __ ] no there's reptile
like there's like um
there's like different alien races yeah
different species apparently they're
already here and then they're they're
battling it out amongst us right and
then so they're saying like mark
zuckerberg or like all the top brightest
and and like world leaders are all
reptilians which are shape shifting
alien creatures that look like reptiles
and if you look at the ancient alien
theory they go well when you see like
egyptian art you see like sumerian art
you see all these like you know hybrid
reptile creatures that are the leaders
and gods of mankind and they're like
they've always been among us and they've
been shape-shifting into humanoid form
and then they're causing destruction and
whatever whatever it's crazy that's
really funny we have all kinds of
different categories like we have the
gray alien who are like the
stereotypical hollywood alien that look
all like small
yeah
and they're they're like on a different
team there's like the humanoid ones that
look like thor
uh they're like the viking ones yeah
right i want to see those they're all
they're they're all just they're all
white people they're like blue eyed
blonde haired norwegian people yeah well
we're probably gonna find out pretty
soon what this thing really is what do
you say it is huh last look what do you
say that is it's a [ __ ] animal dude
just a regular animal some kind of what
always happens is they always come out
and they're like guess what it's not an
alien and we're always like oh wow okay
cool thanks you guys remember as they
scoop it up put an area 51 they're like
keep on researching
you guys remember like like when you're
when we were kids right they would
circulate this dried up picture of a
skate like it's a skate like a fish
it's kind of like a shark and a stingray
had a baby but they flip it the other
way around and it's dried up and it has
a happy face and then people be like we
found a [ __ ] alien
and then man we were all [ __ ] dumb as
[ __ ] back then right because everyone
would think oh my god it'd be on those
uh you know in the grocery store with a
national enquirer yeah
yeah or you're driving to arizona it's
like 140 miles off the road come check
out the alien and you're like
all right i'll check them out
that was me dude
i love that [ __ ] i went for the alien
beef jerky oh yeah oh that's good alien
beef jerky
[Music]